[Music]
lawmakers from both parties will join
veterans today to announce a new effort
in congress
to help service members who say that
toxic burn pits
made them sick more than 3 million u.s
veterans may have come into contact with
dangerous fumes while serving at
overseas basis
where waste ignited by jewel jet fuel
rather was burned in those giant pits
former daily show host that's john
stewart as part of the effort to push
the va into doing more for veterans who
were
exposed chris van cleave is on capitol
hill chris this is a big story good
morning to you
good morning gail think of these burn
pits as basically
giant dumpster fires spewing toxic fumes
they've been linked to some cancers and
other ailments like
lung issues but right now the va
requires a veteran to
prove a link between an illness and burn
pit exposure that can mean paying out of
pocket for blood tests and doctors
and advocates say even then the vast
majority of claims are denied
this new legislation would change that
when you sign up and join the military
you are told you will be taken care of
you're told if you go over
sorry just wait a minute jen howard is
only speaking out because her husband
jason
wanted their story told has your husband
been taken care of
by organizations that help vets yes by
the
va system no a marine veteran jason did
two tours in iraq
while there his wife says he worried
about exposure to toxic fumes from pits
where trash was burned and they
burned pretty much everything they
couldn't necessarily read what all
of the chemicals were because it was in
i guess arabic
they just said it was just smoke fire
burning
waste burning human waste burning
chemical waste
14 years later the quiet dedicated
father began having headaches
within months doctors found the source
glioblastoma
the same terminal brain cancer that
killed president biden's son beau
who spent a year serving in iraq then
candidate biden
brought up the issue of burn pits at a
2019 town hall
because of his exposure to burn pits in
my view i can't prove it yet
he came back with stage four
glioblastoma at least 230 burn pits were
used at bases in iraq and afghanistan
one of the largest balad air base where
a 10-acre trash heap was burning 24
hours a day
seven days a week in 2015 an inspector
general report called it indefensible
that u.s military personnel
who are already at risk fighting
overseas were put at further risk
from the use of open-air burn pits i
kept saying my husband is going to
die before you even give him a yes
or no to get help from the va jason
howard and other suffering veterans have
to first provide a direct service
connection between their ailments and
burn pit exposure
jason's paperwork is still being
reviewed it should not be left to
veterans to dig in their own pockets to
do their own research to hire their own
lawyers
to prove that they were exposed new
legislation from new york senator
kirsten gillibrand would make the
process
easier requiring a veteran prove only
they were deployed in an area where burn
pits were used
in order to qualify for help from the va
if you get any of these diseases any of
these cancers that are known to be
linked with the kind of toxins that were
emitted
that you are presumptively covered and
you will receive the health care
benefits that you've earned
her bill has bipartisan support
republican senator marco rubio is a
co-sponsor
no more bureaucratic studies no more
bureaucratic red tape
and it has some star power attached too
the worst case scenario
is that we grant health care to a
veteran suffering a terrible disease
jon stewart joined the cause two years
ago seeing parallels in his battle to
create permanent benefits for 9 11 first
responders
this is the true cost of war
don't make the veterans pay for your
budgeting error
if you didn't put this into the total
price that's on you
not on the families not on the veterans
that's on the government what is your
message to lawmakers
because they've listened to you in the
past congress is a
a wonderful place to wave a flag well
you can't just say we support the troops
and then abandon them when the troops
need support
the howards hope with this legislation
the next family in their situation
won't spend their last days together
battling
the veterans administration president
biden has said he wants to see this
address senator gillibrand hopes to get
a vote on it this year
the v.a declined comment on pending
legislation but pointed to ongoing burn
pit
research the agency also has a burn pit
registry more than 200
000 veterans and service members have
already signed up but that does not
guarantee them
coverage anthony you sure feel for the
howard family chris thank you very much
i didn't know much about burn pits
no me neither the thanks to jon stewart
too also for speaking up on this and
it's such a drastic difference
when you see her husband before and
after her husband after yeah
i did not realize it was so personal to
joe biden as well or ignorance not
either to joe biden
and as john stewart says as john stuart
says the worst case scenario is you get
you grant health care to suffering
veterans